It’s often hard not to feel envious of them
- as they ascend the stage to collect another
prize, float their start-up company, are promoted
a decade ahead of their peers or dominate
the music charts or bestseller lists. Over-achievers
torment us rather a lot.
But we should, more rightly, combine our envy
with a little compassion. It is likely that
these gifted souls are paying an oddly elevated
price for their extraordinary successes, so
much so that - once their full psychological
profiles are in view - we should start to
feel a bit sorry for the trajectory of their
lives.
What distinguishes over-achievers from the
simply highly talented or driven is what powers
them in their work. They labour principally
or primarily not because they uniquely enjoy
what they do or have more urgent material
demands than the rest of us, but because they
are subject to unusually intense internal,
psychological pressures. Behind their relentless
activity lies an emotional rather than professional
burden. It may look as if they simply want
to sell more books, accumulate more shares
or have their name in lights. But these over-achievers
are all the while trying to secure something
far more tricky, unusual and unmentioned:
they are trying - through their work - to
correct an aspect of a troubled emotional
past. They are trying to impress a father
who felt withholding and severe around them
three decades before. They’re hoping their
triumphs will compensate a parent they loved
for the loss of a sibling in childhood. They
are hoping to assuage a feeling of catastrophe
they experienced in the deprived chaotic home
of their birth.
In other words, over-achievers are trying
to solve a range of psychological problems
through material or worldly means. This is
why their efforts must, in a deep sense, always
be doomed to failure - even when it appears
to most of the world as if they are succeeding
beyond measure.
Because success is the moment when over-achievers
are likely to notice the doomed nature of
their ambition, it is a particularly troubling
and dangerous eventuality. Depression may
set in just after the company is sold; the
star will fall into a crisis just after they
finally gain worldwide recognition. At exactly
the point when their work is acclaimed or
finds its audience, over-achievers are at
risk of severe breakdown. So long as they
are merely running, they can forget to notice
that their goal is misaligned with their true
inner ambition. They must wait for success
to reveal the fateful nature of their life’s
quest.
This also explains why holidays are a particular
trial for over-achievers, for even a few days
off can allow emotional insights to break
through (amidst the palm trees). No rest is
really the optimal state.
The cure for over-achievement involves pausing
to address the psychological wounds that made
hard work feel like the only defence against
intolerable trauma. It means returning to
the situations that made achievement feel
life sustaining. It means a confrontation
with moments of loss, disconnection, lack
of love, sadness and humiliation.
The recovering over-achiever should allow
themselves to feel compassion for their earlier
self, acknowledging how much they wish could
have gone differently and grasping how their
present so-called successful personality has
been shaped as a response to grave wounds.
The cure for over-achievement lies in mourning
and analysis in an atmosphere of love.
The over-achiever may eventually come to believe
that they deserve a place on the earth whether
they work or not. They aren’t there just
to perform. The greater need is to connect
and to understand.
We live in a world very interested in huge
achievements and very uninclined to notice
the trauma behind them. We are equally not
encouraged to note the way in which contentment
with modest achievement can be a sign that
things have gone very well for someone emotionally.
It is evidence of health to have no particular
wish to be famous and not to mind too much
if one doesn’t have a fortune; to be able
to have a so-called ordinary life, to take
pleasure in holidays and to place friendship
and love at the center of things. We should,
on occasion, dare to feel rather sorry for
over-achievers - even if that can mean starting
to feel sorry for ourselves.
We hope you enjoyed this film.  If you want to learn more about Self-Knowledge, follow the link on your screen now.